jc so naturally the silver state schools
credit union the sponsor of this next
segment
wants to help families as their kids
head back to school so we stopped by
their beautiful headquarters
to learn more check it out
i'm scott arkiels president and ceo of
silver state schools credit union
and we're here at our headquarters
building uh to welcome you today
and we wanted to talk to you about our
back to school supply drive
so we're currently accepting new and
unused school supplies for our back to
school supply drive benefiting students
in need in southern nevada
all donations will be distributed by
silver state schools credit union
people over profit foundation also known
as pop foundation
we've partnered with the las vegas
lights football club to accept school
supply donations at cashman field
or at any of our silver state schools
credit unions locations throughout
august 7th here at silver state schools
credit union we are very passionate
about helping our local community
and understanding the importance of our
financial literacy and providing you
with the tools you need to be
financially successful as you go on in
life
one of those tools is our money moves
program it's a free online
financial education center that offers
interactive courses to help navigate
through the financial journey that
you'll have another
resource is the balance program we've
partnered with balance to offer members
free financial guidance services like
live webinars and financial counseling
we also partner with local schools and
programs to introduce financial literacy
to students
and teach them how to be smart savers
i'm often asked if you need to be a
teacher to be
a member of silver state schools credit
union and the answer is not at all
almost anyone can become a member if
you're a member of the education
community
you qualify to be a become a member and
so does your immediate family
if you don't meet that criteria you can
make a one-time donation
to one of our favorite partners vegas
pbs to become a member
and by the way one of your own mercedes
martinez just became a part of the
silver state schools credit union family
by becoming a member along with her
daughters so thank you mercedes for
trusting us as your financial partner
if you want to become a member like
mercedes martinez you can apply for
membership by stopping into any one of
our 10 branch locations
where a member service representative
would be happy to assist you
or you can visit us and apply online at
silverstatecu.com
thank you to silver state schools credit
union for sponsoring this segment in
that little mercedes cameo
for more information call 702-733-8820
or just visit silverstatecu.com we'll be
right back